>> Important point.
Sam kylie, thank you very much.
Let's discuss what's going on.
Joining us now, the nato deputy
secretary general.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Secretary general, for joining
us.
Former Romanian ambassador to
the United States.
What's your reaction to Russia
trying to destroy these patriot
air defense missile battery that
the Ukrainians received from the
United States?
>> It's clear the support all
allies and I like to thank
United States for delivering
military support to Ukraine, the
military build up of Ukraine and
the training they do on very
sophisticated nato type
equipment is of course a concern
to Russia.
Because Russia has quantity.
And they should still be
reckoned with because they are
amassing you know, quantity of
troops and disregard for the
losses they have and Ukraine has
advanced sophisticated western
weapons.
Of course for Russia, that's a
matter of concern.
I have high confidence that the
sophistication of patriot
missile system and also the
fantastic speed and agility,
ingenuity of Ukrainians learning
to use these things.
>> It's been very impressive how
the Ukrainians have learned to
use these.
>> Our guys training them in
America, in Europe, everywhere,
they're really impressed by the
speed.
>> How significant is it right
now, secretary general, that
Russia is admitting losses in
bah mood as Russia strikes
deeper and deeper?
>> The situation, very long
front in Ukraine is very fluid.
We can really witness some
significant advances in the area
by the Ukrainians.
They have the capability to
launch such an offensive.
>> Ukrainians.
They are really mobilizing
troops, equipment, command and
control.
But they're also cautioned to
the fact that Russia is there
with hundreds of kilometers of
three lines of defenses.
They still have quantity.
Ukraine has quality.
Russia has quality.
So we know that Ukraine has the
capacity to launch an offensive
but to be careful and candid in
saying Russia will pose very
fierce resistance ton the front
line.
>> The British foreign secretary
says they may not achieve a
quick, decisive breakthrough in
this expected Ukrainian
counteroffensive against the
Russians but do you agree that
Ukraine will need to manage
expectations here?
>> It's important and I have to
say that the one huge difference
between Ukraine and Russia in
terms of the troops is the level
of morale.
Ukrainians are fighting for
their land.
They're doing a superb and
heroic job and you see that in
the way in which they defend
their freedom.
Russia's morale is very, very
low.
That's why it's very important
also for Ukraine to
strategically communicate
expectations.
I would also say probably the
next few months would be an
indication, not necessarily in a
few days, an indication of the
tide and we hope and know that
Ukraine has the capacity and the
will --
>> Very quickly, you're the nato
deputy secretary general.
Before I let you go.
President zelenskyy of Ukraine
today said he needs clear
signals about Ukraine's future
with nato.
What, if any, future does
Ukraine have with nato?
>> Ukraine deserves and belongs
to civilized Europe.
Ukraine has defended heroically
its freedom.
It's also defending our
interest.
I cannot say in which
circumstances the institutional
part of the integration into the
west would happen but I know
that the place that Ukraine is
with us in civilized Europe part
of the family of democracies.
They earned it.